um this is going to be a little bit of a
different nature from the previous talks
so
a little bit more focused uh a little
bit more technical i mean some of it
i have general slides and then some of
it will be on the whiteboard
um we also have a little bit more time
so i'll try not to abuse it
but this is modular i can easily cut
stuff out so please you know stop me a
lot and ask questions
the audience is kind of diverse probably
so i might be assuming a little bit too
much of you if
i do you know stop me right away um
so i'll talk about uh quantum
multiplayer games
this kind of uh so i mean we've heard a
lot about them uh today already it's a
real that has a long history um
and recently there's been some
interesting progress so the
the goal is to do a couple things i mean
one is to
sort of bring you up to date on some uh
recent results but more than that
try to give you a feeling for the area
right so that you'd uh as
much said maybe you'd feel comfortable
maybe proving your own results uh in the
area or at least uh
sort of using it so it becomes less
intimidating so i don't know if i'll get
there but uh
we'll we'll try so um
that's why there's a question mark right
so let's see um
so i have a little bit of motivation uh
to start so the so i'll
look we'll be looking at those games
from a computational complexity uh point
of view
that's the point of view that's adopted
in in classical computer science the
study of classical multiplayer games
so i'm not going to review those too
much but they have a very uh long rich
history behind them they were introduced
in the
their studies started sort of in the 80s
it was it had two motivations so
motivation came from
cryptography uh people studying the
possibility for having zero knowledge
proof systems
and the other came from complexity
theory we're studying the
notion of interactive proofs and the
games sort of came out of these uh
questions so from cryptography from
complexity theory
very long very active period of work
studying games led to the pcp theorem um
there's you can think of pcp theorem in
many different ways but one of
them is to um you know one of the
points of view that led to the pcp term
is this game's point of view which is
so you can really think of them as um
just a different way to think about
constrained satisfaction problems but
it's a different way
that lets you ask different questions
and maybe um
is more useful to study different kind
of problems
for example the the problem with pilot
repetition is a problem that arises
uh easily when you phrase things at
games as games are less so when you
phrase them as a
constraint satisfaction problems it's
also an area that's still
very active there's a lot of open
questions in the study of classical
multiplayer games or classical
constraint satisfaction problems i'm not
going to go
into them too much so we're going to be
looking at
quantum multiplayer games um and these
are
older and in classical multiplayer games
but we know much less
about them so they're basically asking
for such a theory
that has been developed in the classical
case this is sort of what i want to
try to give a starting point for uh in
my talk
so i'll give you a little bit more
motivation later um so let's see what's
the uh
agenda so on slides i'll give you a few
definitions a little bit of motivation
um i'll state a bunch of open questions
just to just to say what is the the
state of the art in the study of the
multiplayer games
and then um i want to go and switch to
the white board
and try to do what what um said so he he
said
you know i learned it at the same time
as you guys so um that we want to be
giving a sophisticated and basic uh
picture
of the area you said something like this
and actually here my task is easy
because the
area is sort of young and so the basic
picture and the sophisticated picture
basically the same thing uh which is
just the the start of the
the theory that i try to describe so
mostly what i'll focus on is is try to
describe something you could call
uh although it's not usually called like
this a quick levin theorem
for quantum multiplayer games which
would just be
a basic np harness result right if you
think of the quick level theorem saying
that threesat
is np hard it's sort of a basic np
hardness result for constraint
satisfaction problems classical
constraint satisfaction problems
i want to try to give you a flavor of
the same theorem for quantum multiplayer
games
well you know hopefully i get to explain
more uh what i mean
then there'll be some conclusions
is it completely off topic to ask for
the game degree point of
constraint satisfaction yeah next slide
it's on topic thank you
um other questions or i think so you can
ask me again after the next slide
yeah so when you say what approver then
the two prover games was
are also begging for a theory or just in
particular there's three and more two no
no this is two actually most of my talk
will be about two
uh three is special you know begging for
it but um
so it depends what you call theory so so
i'll say you know what is known about
that theory so there is there is a
theory so i guess i
did i call it embryo of a theory
somewhere yeah yeah here so
this is what i described um so i'm not
saying i'm not creating it on the stock
on the spot so so this exists i mean
i'll give citations and
uh um but it does it goes nowhere as far
as this let's say so that's why i'm
saying it's
begging to be developed along the same
lines as hopefully as productively as it
was developed here
all right so this is what i wanted to
start with just to recall
the correspondence between
classical constraints satisfaction
problems and games so i just
phrased them as the same thing and also
this is a way for me to say what these
games are which might not be clear
for everyone so i'll start with a
constraint satisfaction problem
some of you might have seen this before
um it's a particular csp it has nine co
nine variables six constraints so you
can think of these nine variables uh as
being arranged in the little square
that's the nine variables and then the
constraints are that these variables
should be assigned plus minus one values
such that if i take the product of the
variables in any column
i get plus 1 and if i take the product
of the variables in any row
then i get minus 1. so that's the
constraints we can try to satisfy the
constraints column by column
here i got stuck right because x 9 wants
to be plus 1 on the one hand minus 1 on
the other hand
so there's a good reason for this is
that my system of constraints is not
satisfiable
maybe you can see the reason already the
column constraints are saying that the
product of the nine variables should be
plus one
the raw constraints they're saying that
the product should be minus one uh so
this is incompatible right so
i can't tell so but this is just a
constraints affection problem so let's
make it into a game now
so what's the kind of games um i'm
talking about so it's it's like this
i'll
describe it for this square but you
could do it for any uh local constraint
satisfaction problem
so the game is run by the the referee on
this person here
he asks questions to the players
so alice and bob are the two players
they play the game they cooperate they
try to win
in the game but they're not allowed to
communicate throughout they can meet up
beforehand
they know what the rules are they can
decide on the strategy but once the game
has started no talking
so here's the game the referee picks uh
one of the six constraints uniformly at
random and he asks alice about it so for
instance
the second column and then he picks
one of the three variables that appears
in that constraint and asks bob about it
then the players have to reply with
assignments to the values of the
variables they were asked about alice
the three variables bob the one variable
such that um alice's answers satisfy the
constraint
and bob's answer so bob only got to see
one variable right and because he
doesn't communicate he doesn't know
if he was asked x8 as part of the second
column was
as part of the third role right he only
knows x8 he has to
provide an answer to x8 that is
consistent with
what alice said so in that case it works
out he said one she said one so so it's
okay
they're accepted so given a
game in general uh there's one quantity
that we're going to be talking about
throughout the talk which is the maximum
success probability
of the players in the game i'll write it
as omega ms here just means magic square
game it's it's this game in general this
is just g for the game
so it's the maximum success probability
that's taken over the the randomness
that's part of the description of the
game so the referee here
chooses his questions at random and if
the players want they can use randomized
strategies so here maximum success
probability turns out is equal to 17
over 18.
um what's relevant for us is that it's
not one
and the reason it's not one is because
the system of constraints was not
satisfiable
is something that happens in general i
could have started from any csp
make it into a game and you have a nice
correspondence in between
well if the system of constraints had
been inside this fiber
then would it would be clear that you
can win my game with quality one
right just just find an assignment that
satisfies all the constraints and always
answer consistently according to that
fixed assignment
what's also not completely obvious but
what is true is that
um if this thing is not satisfiable then
you cannot win
the game perfectly with probability one
i know if everyone can see this it's
sort of represented here maybe we can do
it on the example of the magic square
and suppose that uh
you can win that game with probability
one and let's look at what bob does uh
in the game
bob is asked just variables and he
provides answers so
in his mind he must have a little table
like this which says well what is
every answer every possible answer that
he could give to every possible question
so we can look at bob's table and if
they win the game with probability one
this table must be consistent with
alice's table alice has a bigger table
she has one
assignment of values for every possible
constraint
but everyone in probability one bob must
be consistent with alice alice must
satisfy the constraints
so bob here this assignment must satisfy
all the constraints in the square
so if they wanted for the one my
constraint satisfaction problem would
have been satisfiable
but it's not so they can't win with
probably one the problem here is that
when bob is asked x9 he says one but
when alice is asked
uh third column there she says minus one
for x9 so they get caught for that
one uh possible question so this
explains this value here this is
something that's very general
um and it has one important consequence
which is that if we know uh that
deciding uh sat is np hard then we have
as an immediate corollary that deciding
whether
given a game deciding whether the value
of this game is equal to one or not one
is a np-hard problem
right um hopefully that's clear because
uh
just because of the previous
correspondence right the value is one if
and only if the formula is satisfiable
so deciding the one is just as hard as
uh deciding the other
so correspondence you can push a little
bit uh further
it's not only that this is satisfiable
if and only if this is perfectly
winnable
it's also that this is almost
satisfiable if and only if this is
almost perfectly
winnable so this correspondence up to
some scaling uh respects the maximum
satisfiability of the constitutional
component the maximum number of clauses
that are simultaneously satisfiable
the pcp theorem so if you accept the pcp
theorem says that
approximating the maximum number of
clauses that are simultaneously
satisfiable in the three-state formula
to within uh some small constant factor
this then be hard so as a consequence
we also get that approximating the value
of these games isn't be hard
right so that's for classical games now
we look at quantum games uh
quantum multiplayer games the main
difference
is just going to be this now i consider
strategies for my players
that still do not allow communication
but might use entanglement so the two
players come up
start the game sharing an entangled
state and then they can make
upon receiving their questions they'll
make a measurement on their share of the
state
this measurement will produce outcomes
and they can use these outcomes
directly as their answers or do some
post-processing whatever they want and
they send the
answers back right so we all know
i think everyone knows i mean does
everyone has a background in quantum
information here or
are some people just curious
sort of assuming because of the previous
talks i'm assuming everyone knows a
little bit of quantum but
well if you don't you know speak up
so this entitlement is going to allow
for correlations
um well we've seen the chs game right so
everyone has seen such things
so their success probability might
increase um and this is what happens uh
in this game
see it's here it's it's very striking um
because there is a strategy that uses
entanglement which is a pair of vpr
pairs it's a very simple strategy and it
wins in this game with probability
exactly one
it's very striking because it means that
this nice correspondence we had
completely breaks down
because the constraint satisfaction
problem is the same i didn't change the
square it's still not satisfiable
exactly same situation as before but now
i can win the game uh with probability
one
so these are the questions uh you know
so so
why how come i can win the game 41 even
though this constraint of
system of constraints is still not
satisfiable
and that's because um this here this
arrow doesn't exist anymore
right the quantum strategy if i think
about what is bob doing
before he was classical and i could say
for every question he has an answer and
let's list the answers
now he's using a quantum strategy this
quantum strategy involves measuring his
state so for every question he has a
measurement
so i can make a table of measurements
there's no way that i can say well you
know
what would he answer if he was asked x1
and x2 and x3 and x4 this would involve
repeatedly measuring the state but if
the measurements are incompatible
there's no meaningful way in which to
make this repeated measurement
since the table would depend on the
order in which i make the measurements
there's something that broke down um we
allow quantum strategies and we lose the
fact that
to every uh strategy in this game we
could associate some global object which
was just the list of all possible
answers
quantum strategies only have a local
nature they only let you define for
every pair of questions
the probability distribution on answers
that arises from making the
corresponding measurements
so this is why this thing broke down is
it a problem
yes what's the problem with breaking a
table that's for each
question for alice uh gives the
projected measurement on the
the state like the projected state on
that uh
yep so we can do that we can have a
table so the one i suggested was for
every question to write down what is the
measurement
and maybe the state i mean the state is
the same all the time and you're
suggesting the post measurement state
maybe or something
yeah no that table exists but it um i
can't it doesn't
i can't link it back to this to my to
the constraint satisfaction problem
what i can't create is a consistent i
mean a sense of meaningful
uh assignment of values but of course i
can say what this
quantum strategy is and we see it later
i mean it's a complete object indeed
there's just a bunch of matrices it's
all
but there's no assignment no global
assignment
um yeah so when you look at the left
so does it make sense to say you are
looking for a quantum solution or it
does not make sense um
so you are definitely looking for a
classic yes
so um there's many interpretations you
could give to giving a quantum solution
um um one is
exactly this one we'd say that the
classical constant satisfaction problem
has a quantum solution if and only if
there is a quantum strategy that
succeeds 41 in the associated game
and that's kind of the point of view
that i'm going to take in the talk
because we're interested in the games to
start with not necessarily the
constraints that's the problem
but you could have others or you can
think of a quantum solution to a csp
like this as a
non-commutative version of the classical
solution and in that particular example
this is not something i'm going to go
into but it's i think it's interesting
question so i'll just mention it
the reason why i mean one way to think
of the reason why
or this successful led is one in that
case is exactly that there
is no classical solution to the csp but
there's a non-commutative solution so in
what sense
in the sense that there exists a bunch
of nine matrices
x9 so you can think of them
as in that particular case they're just
four by four
complex matrices um their hermitian
and they square two identities they have
plus minus one eigenvalues so this kind
of the correspondence and they satisfy
all equations in the sense that for
example
x1 times x2 times x3
matrix product um is equal to the
identity
etcetera and then the one that needs to
be minus one will equal minus eight this
is the kind of thing i want so yeah
that's very cool actually yeah i like
but i i want to say
that this translation from the
from this csp to this game
is slightly artificial because
like the because if it was a bipartite
game
you wouldn't have to yes like on one
side
you wouldn't have to do the variables
and on the other side the constraints
but
you could just you could just do the
constraints and that would be the
natural translation
if it's bipartite you start with you are
already designing
kind of a like a translation method
which is
which is not carved in stone in
something so that's a very good point
sorry in this case in that case i could
in this case you could but
it's you couldn't do it always
it's not bipartite you couldn't do it
you could do this always but not yeah
yeah so this is why
so you're right you're completely right
on this there's some arbitrariness
and uh there's many ways in which you
could think of making such
transformation if the csps bipartite
there's a maybe perhaps more natural one
um classically they're all equivalent
they'll sort of preserve the maximum
satisfiability quantum it's not
clear at all that they're equivalent and
so i just want to say to that
is that when you do this translation
like classically
then you translate a csp to another csb
in a sense
and and there is a difference between
i mean the new csp has this extra
structure
and when for instance it comes to the
pro repetition
then for games with this extra structure
it's
easier to prove the repetitions theorem
than without this extra structure right
the projection
proof is is easier than
let's say the rundra's proof but okay so
these are very good points um so the
reason i'm choosing i'm not i also don't
intend to set this transformation in
stone
what i'm interested in is studying
complexity theory of
multiplayer games not necessarily of
csps
um so i'm interested in any kind of
game that arises from a csp in this way
or not
the reason i'm taking this
transformation is just because
i want to use the classical theory of to
prove things about
the games themselves um but you're right
and this is one reason why
i'd be way of saying what is a quantum
solution to a constraint satisfaction
problem because you know so we've
already seen two different things i mean
you suggested some more
yeah but this feels like a quantum
solution to that
no that's a non-commutative solution to
that but it doesn't have just like a
good site i mean this this field is
carved in stone as opposed to this
transfer it is
it is but it has the um
it has the advantage that it's uh
mathematically natural uh
and i think this is very it is very
interesting um the reason i'm sticking
with this
is that uh this is what
um arises in quantum theory i mean this
is the thing that you'll be able to
apply this is that what shows up in
device independence this is what shows
up when you study entanglement
non-locality
so this is the i mean if you're
interested in kind of information it's
this would give you you know probably
insights but it's
this is the real problem so this is what
um but i agree
certainly lots of nice things to be said
about it
can you that quantum formulation
can you use that to devise the strategy
can you extract the strategy that they
use yes so um this is a stronger
requirement
than succeeding in the game so if you
give me such matrices i'll
i'll come up with a strategy for this
particular game again this is not
something very general
one nice thing to observe about about
this um
you know how come this is possible just
uh because before we said this is not
possible how did we prove it
we multiplied all the nine variables in
two different ways right by columns and
by rows and we said well the product
should be the same it can't be one and
minus
one here it's okay with the matrices
because if you multiply the nine
matrices by
rows or by columns again you get the
product of the nine matrices but in
different orders right by rows or by
columns so it's fine that
it would be identity and minus segment
this is an exercise coming out of these
matrices they're four by four the tensor
products of poly matrices it's it's easy
to talk a little bit more um
about what is happening here connect to
things that maybe some
in the audience know i wanted to relate
oh and also to the title of my talk uh
which was supposed to be about
semi-definite programming
so this situation where here um
what i said is what happens with quantum
strategies is that they have this local
existence for every pair of questions
you have distribution on answers
but you don't have a distribution on
answers to all possible questions
jointly only the ones that arise in the
game
this is also something that happens
when you study linear programming or
semi-definite programming relaxations of
constraint satisfaction problems or
classical
multiplayer games i won't say too much
about this if you don't know about sdps
sdp relaxations for csps then you won't
follow the slide but it's
it's okay um where you have this
constraint satisfaction problem here the
constraints are on the edges
you take the relaxation sdp relaxation
the sdp relaxation will give you vectors
associated with each variable such that
when you take you know like
something like the inner products of the
vectors along the edges you can
interpret that
as a distribution on assignments to the
pair for example x1 x4
that is going to satisfy the constraint
with high probability
so given any pair of vectors you have a
distribution on answers
or assignments for that particular edge
but there's no distribution no global
distribution to all the variables that
you can extract just from the vectors
themselves
this is what you do when you start the
sdp hierarchies you try to build upon
that
so quantum setting is is very similar to
that with local existence no global
existence
um we have a little bit more structure
and this is what we want to try to be
using when we study quantum multiplier
games what differentiates them
just from these vectors here so i'd say
what quantum strategies are but
they're not just vectors they're
matrices these matrices are
sometimes positive some type of bounded
operator norm
um we will get more um into that
i just wanted to point out the
connection at that level and i'll make
it again
later because this is just one side
we've seen this already i just want to
motivate so from the physics point of
view why do we study these games
and they started from my channel
podolski rose and they didn't call it a
game they called it a thought experiment
but the
this is what happened to them i mean
they observed that uh
seems that quantum mechanics predicts
these very strong correlations that can
be obtained by measuring particles that
are space-time separated
and this is sort of contrary to
intuition or depending how you phrase it
it can be contrary to intuition and the
way they phrased it it was contrary to
equation and so
but then so there was lots of confusion
but then um mush mentioned this i mean
bell came along
30 years later and he reformulated uh
their paradox in a more mathematically
sound way
um you know just by saying you know
there's no cause causations
causation so there's no communication in
between these particles it's just that
the
distributions that you generate have
correlations they have stronger
correlations that you could do
classically or that you could do using
local hidden variables
and then later uh cluster horner shimoni
and halt
built upon bell by creating this chsage
game they called it chsh inequality so
this was a
much simpler formulation even than what
bell had and the
great advantage of their simple
formulation is that it lend itself to
making experiments so then
this still was a game you could think of
this as a game with continuous inputs uh
outputs this is a game with two inputs
two outputs
per player so you can do the experiment
it's been done many times verified um so
quantum mechanics is non-local uh
we have to deal with it this is why we
understand one of the big motivations
why you want to understand these games
in the first place
um this is the kind of questions that
arise when you study the games the kind
of
questions that come from foundations of
quantum mechanics mostly you want to try
to understand entanglement
and these correlations that you can
generate from entanglement
but recently there's a whole new array
of questions and applications of
quantum multiplayer games that's been
surfaced in surfacing and we
heard about these applications in the in
the previous talk uh so not i'm not
going to go over there
more and we might hear more about them
later
uh in the week
all right so uh these are my games i've
sort of said this already but just
again say the model what are the games
we consider they could have any number
of players
only going to be two players in this
talk which could be three players four
players
um they can also have in principle more
than one round of interaction although
again i'll stick to games with that have
one round of interaction for the for the
talk but you could think of them as
being a bit more general
um and the main quantity is this maximum
probability of acceptance right and the
game again
is specified explicitly to everyone so
everyone has a complete list of all the
possible questions in the game what is
the probability that this question is
being asked
all the possible answers and what are
those valid answers everyone knows that
the only thing they don't know is which
question the other guy's got and that
is what makes it hard to to play in the
game
so if there is no star this omega here
this will be the classical value the
optimum over classical strategies
um and we already saw this so this is a
quantity that's np
hard to approximate as a result of the
pcp within constant factors
i mentioned this um so then the one we
look at is the omega star so this is the
maximum success probability of quantum
strategies so
they can use entangled states
and this we don't know um or well i'll
say what we know but the
the the question that i'm asking here
that we want to be studying is what is
the complexity
of computing or approximating this
quantum value world
we saw proof of the of this here i mean
assuming pcp theorem
we saw that proof broke down when you
studied this value and now suddenly we
don't know
um given a description of the game can
we figure out what is the maximum
success probability of quantum players
in the game when what is the optimum
strategy
it could be easier it could be harder
the one thing we know
is that this value is larger than this
value this is clear i'm allowing you one
more resource
you have to do better for instance if
this value was always equal to 1 if you
could always win with 41 it would be a
very easy problem
we don't expect this to be the case but
but we don't know right so
um questions so far so now i have okay
what's
coming up i have three slides of um sort
of
state-of-the-art open questions that i'm
going to flash by
relatively fast just to give you a
flavor of where the area stands
what kind of questions people ask what
kind of techniques are used
some of it will be lost but i'll get
back to them at the end of the talk once
i've showed you
shown you these open questions i will
get to the board um
and you know we'll start talking about
this in a little bit more detail i'll
formalize the situation a little bit and
tell you you know what we do
yeah so the the problem is well defined
but are you going to explain more
why it is important and why we should
care about it no so which problem
so you can ask you know um
so where do we get i think you care
right because you've written papers
where
uh you study games um and you've
observed
that it's it's usually sort of hard to
work with these games because you have
few analytic tools right and actually
one of the class of games you focus on
in your papers are xor games
which is the one class of quantum games
for which we know an answer to this and
the answer is we can compute it in
polynomial time
and i think we've observed that i mean
the reason it can be computed in polymer
time is because
there's a semi-definite programming
formulation for
computing this value in the particular
case of extra games and that's extremely
useful right because we have an sdp we
have algorithms
under that is some structure that can be
used to study device independence i mean
these questions in the
than i ever said end and i'm not sure
about it but uh
but but for for so for that paper i
think our already in what we use
is the property yes
yeah yeah so i think i mean this is this
is something
you could ask the general this is maybe
a general question about complexity and
i should let
you know the experts answer my my
understanding of this is is this is just
this is an object it's like a the basic
object is a multiplayer game this you
want to understand because it has to do
with foundations entanglement it's using
device independence it's sort of a
abstract concept that shows up a lot you
want to understand it
so you want to be working with it and
this question of what is the complexity
this is like a basic question that will
let you categorize
you know which games maybe are easy to
work with which games are hard to work
with
it's it's sort of a basic high-level
question that you're asking
you know answering this doesn't have any
direct applications but it has a
uh bearings on the understanding um
so it's not like i wouldn't say for
example a similar
flavor question is when you study
quantum pcp theorem right we'll talk
about
tomorrow i think aaron a little bit
friday
where there you try to really connect
the complexity to your question with
uh the physical question what is the
complexity of quantum states
here i'm not trying to do that i'm just
saying you know this is a basic object
that shows up a lot i want to understand
this the object and the lens my lens is
complexity theory
um if i come up with polynomial time
algorithms this is great because it'll
mean i have found some structure that's
useful
um if i show that some np harness result
well it means that it's you know
it's complex oh but yeah i know that
answers
i mean if like classically
the the two very correspond
correspond to constraint satisfaction
problems
and solving constraints and inspection
problems
is np hard and you would guess that
like quantumly solving correspond
to quantum constraints satisfaction
problems
yeah so so where is the catch uh you
will tell about the catch no this is an
open question there is no catch
let me get let me get to my questions
and don't correspond to
quantum constraints of inspection
problems
what's a quantum constraint satisfaction
problem local hamiltonian
system no no this is okay this i'm not
going to get into because this is uh
no let me do the next slide okay
so um what's very briefly what's known
and what are the open questions on this
problem that i've been raising computing
or approximating the
uh rectangle value right so
two of this observation i mean one is
it's a quadratic optimization problem
just because alice bob just like in the
classical case
but there's no upper rebound on the
dimension of the strategies that they'll
be using
so there's no obvious upper bound on the
complexity in this of this problem
and fall we know there's also not any uh
sorry there's no obvious upper bound and
there's no known upper bound so we don't
know
so this problem could be as complicated
as you want oh
there's no upper bounds particularly
could be qma hard very well we don't
know
um there's particular issues that arise
when you try to define
the value for infinite dimensional
strategies um i'm not going to get into
these so
for me i'll you know we'll only focus on
finite dimensional strategies here
so for that case you can define uh
there's a semi-definite programming
hierarchy
which provides better and better upper
bounds it converges in the limit but
there's no bound on the
rate of convergence so you don't it
doesn't give you any
upper bound convergence
but you don't know um so what is the
dimension of a strategy
let's say the dimension of the entangled
state you know
alice's times bob's for example
i'll get to that also when we sort of
start writing an equation but um
so upper bounds there's none on this
problem we don't know it could be very
hard
lower bounds uh for a long time there
was few now we know
um um we know a little bit so one thing
we know is that exactly computing this
uh entangled value is np hard
this result from 2008 to 2009
and this is basically what i'm going to
sort of prove for you not
in full detail but almost all details so
you'll know how to prove this how we get
around the difficulty that
that we had before we also know that
it's for the case where you allow
more than two players you allow three
players or more then we know that the
problem of computing approximating the
value is a np-hard problem so it's
it's a hard problem this is even true
for three-player xor games
so these are the best lower bounds that
we know these are kind of techniques
that go up in proving the lower bounds
are not going to
insist um in some cases uh
we have polynomial time algorithms
basically two cases one i already
mentioned two player xo games
and then a slight generalization
two-player unique games
um so for these two classes of games
these special types of games
there are polynomial time algorithms
based on the use of semi-definite
programming
that give you very good in that case
exact
computation of the value in that case a
good approximation
to the omega star quantity
but i won't describe those a big open
question here
is what happens for general two-player
games right that's i would say that's
the major open question
in the urea for three player games we
know that it's at least np hard
maybe it's qma hard i don't know but
it's at least np hard
two player games in some cases we have
algorithms but these are very specific
kinds of games
more general games we don't we don't
know my guess would be it should be and
be hard but but it's not it's not
proving
so open question you cannot think of it
as a
search for pcp theorem or yeah you can
there's one definition of what it would
be
yeah so i guess quantum pcb is already
taken so
i i for the local hamiltonian problem um
and they're they're they're different so
that's why i'm not saying it but yeah
you know how right right yeah i mean
this
could be just as well right yeah it
could be called pcpa and pcp
yeah let's find better names but yeah
sorry what do you call it the last line
last line i mean i guess positive answer
to the last line yeah
you could so you know in a way i mean
then there's this result right and you
could say well that's which result
the np hardness but for three players
right right so then you can insist on
having two players which is what i'm
doing here because it's
so so basically you're saying well in
the classical pcp theorem
two players is the same as having a
proof yeah and here it's not
yep in the quantum case it's not and so
it's in the quantum case uh local
hamiltonians is the same as having a
proof
and two players is a different thing
yeah
yeah i mean that's the problem it's just
that there's are
you're not agreeing with the use of pcp
theorem for this i don't know no no i i
don't mind using this
i'm just clarifying i'm saying that
there are three different concepts here
okay what are the three
okay so so um so classically
uh you know there are three things that
are the same right one one is
uh one is constrained satisfaction
though there's uh
that is you write out a proof and how
many bits do you want to access
and the third one is multiplayer you
know two provers
and these are all the same yeah
importantly uh
constrained satisfaction corresponds to
local hamiltonian
proof quantum proof you just have a
quantum proof which you access
constantly many those two are the same
okay and then this is a third one where
you have two groupers and that's not the
same okay and that's not the same
exactly for the reasons that
thomas showed with the magic square
where classically
you know you ask one player one question
and then that defines a truth assignment
and then the second one yours how many
constraints do you satisfy
whereas the fact that he did cheat and
you know there's this cheating quantum
strategy in
magic squares really illustrates that
it's not the same thing
necessarily yeah um
yeah i didn't get into that because i
wanted to avoid it but it's an important
clarification
right so i have more open problems
related to the structure of these when
you think of them as interactive proofs
i'm going to skip that
um maybe just so the last open problems
slide because it has to do with uh
questions uh
you know from that rise from the study
of these games but that have to do with
specifically respect to the entanglement
uh that's used in the
in the games so some um
you know some interesting i mean one of
the motivations for studying the games
is to understand
different entangled states you take a
game and you ask you what kind of
entanglement is the optimal
entanglement that you can use in the
game and there's some interesting things
that that happened there that i'm not
going to go
into but for instance for those of you
who know like a natural state to be
using is maximally entirely state
but this is not always the best state to
be using in games there's
other types of states they're called uh
they're universal states they're called
embezzlement
um states so you have nice
um that's a question um
the the the interesting or some of the
interesting questions have to do
with this dimension problem that i
mentioned already right or given a game
even a very simple game
uh how much entanglement do you need in
order to play
well optimally or near optimally in this
game
um really so strikingly it is an answer
a question that we have no
answers to i find it extremely
surprising i'm not going to do it but i
could write on the board
an example of a game that has very
similar to magic squarely like three
questions
three answers very simple i can't say
anything about how much entanglement is
needed
to win the game optimally or even near
optimally
not even a law of decreasing returns you
know saying that
at some point it just doesn't help to
have more and more entanglement you're
doing only slightly better but not more
we don't know what we do have is a lower
bounds so we have examples of games for
example here there's these are extra
games
that have n questions per player
and we know that to succeed in these uh
n question xor games with success
probability that's
at least the optimum minus epsilon you
need
a number of qubits that scales
polynomial in the number of questions
times epsilon right so as you allow
more error or well whatever
what whatever it should be um uh
but there's no upper bounds so um
and there's even some some kind of cute
uh little games for which it seems that
if you want to play at least if you want
to play optimally in the game
you need infinite dimensional
entanglement like if you put a cap on
the amount of entanglement then you're
not being optimal
but they're not games as i've described
them there's two examples known
so far there's examples of games that
have two players but the questions are
quantum
it's not something i'm getting into but
they have this property that you need
infinite entanglement to play optimally
and there's another example where the
questions and answers are classical
in fact there's only two questions per
player but the players are allowed to
give answers that are arbitrarily long
so classical answers but they can be
arbitrarily long
it's not required in the game but but
it's allowed and for that game also you
probably need infinite entanglement to
win it or infinite dimensional to win it
with the optimal
success problem this is a
quick flash to maybe just just a flavor
if you haven't
understood all the questions it doesn't
it's not so important i'll get back to
some of them or maybe at the end
but now let's see so we won't run
through all of this so don't worry maybe
i should stop
here so what's coming up so um
we have about 45 minutes left so so this
should be enough so
what do i want to do um i want to get
back to this
uh magic square game but more general
we'll do the same game but for three
start right so start from the three side
formula and define the game in the way
that we did before
and i want to analyze this game so i
want to just tell you how we describe
the quantum strategies with what happens
how you work with them mathematically
there's going to be a couple of
equations and then i want to sort of
start
describing what the theory that you
could come up
for working with these quantum
strategies like a theory of
tests and gadgets and reductions
i won't give you too many of those but
first i'll describe a way to measure
proximity between different strategies
this is like saying you know strategies
that give almost always the same answers
but
for quantum strategies it's not trivial
so i'll describe this
and then i'll describe a couple of
little gadgets uh one of these gadgets i
call the confusion game
this is a gadget that you're going to be
able to compose with the game and it's
going to enforce
some kind of partial commutativity
between the strategies
kind of get rid of this example that we
had here in the in the case of the magic
square
and so there's a going to be a bunch of
applications for this confusion
gadget one of them is that we'll prove
this np harness result for the
for the quantum value then there's other
applications that i probably won't have
time
to get into one of them is a direct
product testing of quantum strategies
with application to parallel repetition
um
something i probably won't go into also
is going further you know going from
hardness of computing to hardness of
approximating i'll say more about this
maybe
later i don't think i'll give you any
details
and you could do um more so you could
come up with
other types of games or gadgets to prove
these lower bounds i guess i mentioned
this here just to say that the kind of
stuff that we're going to go through
lets you prove not only what i'll prove
but also many other of the things that
i've
described oops and that was it that was
it
so you have questions on
what happened so far uh where we're
going why we're doing it
this is a good time to stop me so um
no so i'll stick to the model of games
that i explained
the transformation this is how my
three-star game is going to be defined
but then i'm actually going to um add in
some little gadgets so because this
transformation
that i described from constraint
satisfaction problem to game
is not sufficient to get np harness
result we saw that in the magic square
game it it's it's not good as a
transformation
so actually what i want to do is change
it tweak it a little bit
make it a bit of a stronger
transformation so now we have something
that works so if the csp is not
satisfiable
the game is not winnable but on the game
sides you always talk about the same
kind of two players
classical questions yeah yeah
other questions maybe just a resolution
ambiguity the tyrson
the fact that the two definitions of
omega star is slightly confusing there's
two definitions
you said that there's two different
definitions of omega star in the limit
foreign
oh yeah not in the limit in in the
infinite dimension
yes and since you haven't bounded
entanglement that doesn't
mess things up for you um no so no
because
i'm going to choose one definition i
guess so i'll i'll define
um what finite dimensional strategies
are right and then there's going to be a
well-defined limit as d goes to
infinity and this you know will be
monotone so it'll converge to something
i could come up with a different
definition that's directly infinite
dimensional
that might not coincide with my limit
definition
but i'm not going to use i'm going to
use the limit definition
other questions
okay
all right so i was looking for
so the first point was just to go back
to this game threes that game
i'm going to describe the game again and
describe what strategies are in the game
it would be a tragedy to write in the
middle um
no but i mean the the thing the problem
is
you write stuff and then once you open
the things um you lose it right so
i don't know if you really make oh this
is not a white i was going to write on
this thing
okay exactly okay thanks okay okay okay
good
so i hope you're not too worried i mean
i'm trying to keep this
light there's going to be a little bit
of notation but um it won't get much
worse
that it's going to get in the next 10
minutes so
um okay i'm going to make um
one assumption about the kind of games
that i consider which is that they treat
all the players
symmetric symmetrically so all the games
assumption it's not a crucial assumption
it's a convenient
assumption so all games treat players
symmetrically
which means that who plays alice and who
plays bob
is not set in stone but it's decided
randomly at the start of the game so
there's two players one and two
and each of them will receive a question
saying you're playing alice and here's
your question
you're playing bob and here's your
question and then this there'll be a
random
permutation and they all have to succeed
at all if
if they're both told they're out right
they want to be both told alice but
yeah yes wait then don't they have to be
consistent
in that case
no no so this is a very important point
actually um
yeah umesh is right but leonard was also
right so this is
uh later on um we're going to change the
games as i mentioned
um there's different little gadgets that
we put in and one of these will be that
sometimes with some probability
we're actually going to tell both of
them your alice and ask both of them to
give the same answer
but i'll explain that this is something
an extra layer that we're putting
on top of the requirement it'll be an
extra requirement because it's not
without loss of generality
it'll be very it'll be useful but we'll
do that later
so what are strategies there are three
elements there's a quantum state and
then actually two elements quantum state
and measurements right
so the quantum state uh this is just
this unit vector d
in d dimensions c d d squared i guess c
d tensor c d
i use the same d uh for alice and bob's
dimensions
d is any uh integer and then there's
measurements because the players are
treated symmetrically there's not really
alice or bob's measurements there's just
for every question that you can be asked
and i always implicitly
assume that when you ask a question you
know if it's an ali's kind of question
or bob kind of question right you're not
going to make the difference so there's
just a set of questions q
and then for every question so for every
question
q and q there's a measurement so this
measurement is a
povm a q a right so it's a bunch of
d-dimensional matrices indexed by the
answers
and they satisfy the usual conditions so
they're positive
and they sum to identity
i'm calling all of them a so far because
i'm just putting
all the questions into one question set
thinking of this island's bob thing as
being part of the
of the label of my question what's povm
um yeah it's it's this so it's it's it's
a
positive operator valued measure and
it's just um
it's it's it's the name that we give to
these two conditions there
when they do this or you see me there
okay because i was seeing you yeah
so it's just saying it's just a
measurement it's a general measurement
okay the requirement is that they're
positive matrices that sum to identity
right so for those of you not really
familiar with the quantum formalism for
the
throughout the whole talk you can think
of these as if it's easier as projector
matrices
so they have zero one eigenvalues and
they sum to identity
one way to think of them is the
partition of the identity
they're just subspaces each aqa projects
on a subspace
and for every question you have a bunch
of orthogonal subspaces uh each
orthogonal sub
each of the subspaces is labeled by a
possible answer wait what's greater than
equal to zero
uh here yeah sorry so please do this uh
when i write poorly because
i mean oh yeah sorry
so for example a projection satisfies
these
and you know we can think of projections
okay and so there's one important uh
thing that i have to say which is
this is this is it that's it that's a
strategy
um what kind of distributions on answers
does this strategy give rise to right
this is just the measurement
rule so i'll write it like this given i
fix a strategy what is the probability
that i provide a pair of answers a and a
prime
given that i was asked questions q and q
prime
there's different ways you can write
this i'll write a few different ways so
the standard quantum information way to
write it is like this
a q a a q prime a prime
i hope you're not confused by the fact
that they're both a's right but this is
like a nice question this is a bob
question
sorry
that's the standard way to write it
another way to write it is to say that
this is
um uh
i see let me write it uh in a way that
might be useful
as an inner product between two vectors
so now these are two complex vectors how
did i define them
uqa i define as applying the matrix aqa
to the left-hand side of my state side
and the other is it should be a u-prime
or u-tilde or whatever
it's a q prime a-prime applied to the
right-hand side so this is the same this
is just notation for this inner product
between two vectors
but this maybe connects it to this
semi-definite programming thing that i
mentioned before
so these quantum probabilities they're
like inner products of vectors but with
additional structure they're not any two
vectors they're vectors that can be
written as the result of applying
a matrix on ornamental state
and i'll give you one more uh way to
think about this which is something that
i was first taught by a classical
computer scientist this is
we were talking about these things and
she had a very different way to think
about these probabilities
which i find useful so let me write it
for you
so i'll rewrite this in a different way
again
equivalent way
as a trace of a product
transpose is transposition applied to a
and there's a k
here that showed up this k is a
different way to think of the entangled
state so
i'm out of space i'm going to use this
here and then i'll erase it
k is just a square matrix that has as
coefficients
of the state the coefficients of the
state
uh let's say i would write it like this
or consider it each
something like this the ijt coefficient
of the state side
if you can't parse this don't don't
worry about it actually
for all practical purposes you can think
of k as being the identity matrix
in that case i'm just taking trace inner
product between two matrices
but here's another way of thinking of
these states and probabilities
the state you can represent as a square
that's psi
it's a big square it's indexed the rows
are indexed by basis vectors on alice's
space
so here this is alice and the columns
are indexed by
basis vectors on bob's space
inside here are the coefficients of psi
so inside here i have a bunch of
coefficients
they're complex numbers and the sum of
the squares is one that's the
normalization condition
so entangled state is any table like
this table
that has complex numbers and the sum of
the squares is one
okay now alice's strategy are operators
that act on the left hand
side here and bob's act here and you can
think of
any measurement that alice makes as
partitioning the rows
into a different partition here so let's
say
no there's only two possible outcomes
she makes a partition like this
that's alice's choice of measurement bob
makes another choice maybe that's his
choice of measurement this partition
and then what's the probability that
they get a certain pair of outcomes the
probability that alice gets the outcome
associated to this half of the partition
and bob the one associated to this half
is the sum of the squares of the
coefficients
here so the sum of the squares is of
every one is one so it's consistent and
you know if that's helpful to anyone but
that's one way you can think of how
these probabilities are generated
with one twist which is that alice can
not only choose you know subsets of rows
for her different answers that she's
going to measure in
she can apply a random unitary uh an
arbitrary unitary
on this side before making her selection
right and this
choosing different unitaries correspond
to the fact that different measurements
don't commute
if she was always simply choosing a
subset of rows and
bob the subset of columns this would be
a classical strategy
maybe this helps maybe it doesn't um i'm
going to be working with this formula
but i just wanted to say
maybe a different way of different ways
of thinking about it
but that's what i needed to say about
strategy so is it clear my notation
um it's okay
that so k is the
is the function that defines the game or
is the underlying probability
distribution
or it defines the underlying probability
distribution of the
true
is just another way to think of the
state you can think of this state
this state has d squared coefficients
and i can think of them you know as a
long vector that has d squared
coefficients
or as a d by d matrix and that's what k
there's no game so far
okay so and what defines the game
is the it's not defined yet but it would
be
no it would be what is the set of
questions what is the set of answers
yeah and you know with what probability
do i choose these questions and what are
the valid answers
okay so let me define the game now
unless there's another question
okay um so the game uh to start with
is the same game that we saw before so
this um so i
take five will be a three-star formula
so generalization of i mean not really
but so it has clauses
c1 up to cm and
these clauses act on variables
x1 up to xn
right and so the game is like this
so the first step we do what what i said
before in terms of symmetrization so
we choose
alice bob at random so
by this i mean we tell each player you
know you're going to play alice you're
going to play bob
one way or the other so there's no two
alices one is alice the other is bob
then we choose a random clause
also uniformly at random and we choose
uh choose j and then
a random variable in that clause so i'm
going to be a little bit sloppy and i'll
write it this way
random in the clause this is just one of
the three variables
uh the clause acts on and then
we send the clause
to alice and the variable to bob
okay and then the last step is that we
receive answers
so alice is supposed to give us uh three
values because she was asked about the
whole clause the three variables
abc formatis
and another value from bob
and then we'll check that
alice's answers satisfy the clause which
i'm going to write just like this
satisfy cj and we also check
consistency here i don't want to write
this formally
so this is just saying that you know
whichever variable bob was asked about
he gives the same answer as as that is
right
it's the same game this is the same game
as before nothing new there
all right so so that's the game um
now the players can use any strategy um
what's the quantum value of the game so
the up the optimum success probability
how do
i define it so i'll define it in this
way
of this particular game g5
will be the supremum over all strategies
so overall dimensions
states and measurements
and i have for every question i have a
measurement
here the questions are of two types
clauses and variables so i have two
types of measurements
so i'll write them i have the a
which are indexed by clauses and they
provide
traits as answers and then i also have
the b's
i call them b's which are indexed by
variables
actually i called this w
so so that's your strategy and i'm
taking the supreme world strategies of
what the success probability so what's
the success probably
is that write down what happens in the
game so what happens in the game is
first i choose the clause at random
then i choose a random variable in that
clause so i'll have
one third all possible variables
in the clause and then i send this over
and i'm going to count score when you
give a correct answer so what's the
probability you give a correct answer
it's the sum of all possible answers or
the probability you give that answer
so i'll sum over all a b c
which satisfy the clause
and then d i'm not summing over because
d should just be whatever value it's
supposed to be because of the
consistency
and then the probability will just be
what we had on the board on the left
hand side
so i have a cj abc
censored b s
d where d i haven't defined because it's
a bit of a pain but it's you know
whatever
the consistent it's one of abc depending
on what what the question was
right that's the definition that that's
the quantity that we're looking at
is it can you go and read me here so i
i just want to say so i i of course i
studied multiple hair games
and so i understand the definition it's
hard to understand it for the first time
you see it for the first time yes
anyways but i think that's very nicely
comes out like in your in your
blackboards that on the left
is the correlation what the players
actually are making
and in the middle that's the definition
of the game
the correlation that actually you want
to achieve
and what is on the third slide is kind
of the inner product between the tools
so that's the mathematical so the
correlation what we can
achieve and the correlation what we want
to achieve so we want to get
them as close as possible and that's
what that
formula is yeah right that's
yeah you can think of games as linear
functions on the space of
straight or of correlations and um
then of course we want to pick our
matrices aqs
such that that's best achieved yes
so and what you're saying is also also
true when you study
um the classical value so
one remark is that you you you should
you might be able to see that if i
if i set d to one
um so i don't take supreme over d i
force it to be one
then
let's write it like this right d1 then
this is just
the classical value this is just
classical assignments because if i if
you
look at what's the strategy when v
equals one the state is a one by one
state it's it's nothing it's a complex
number so it's just a phase it goes away
and then these positive psd matrices
which sum to identity
um they're just a distribution they're
positive real numbers that sum to one
so they're just a distribution so i'm
saying for d equals one for every
question i have a distribution on
answers that's a classical strategy
so when i said d to one here i'll this
is just one way to express what is the
option what you're saying is that the
middle board does not change
only that clause yeah we cannot achieve
as many
correlations or as wide range of
correlations as quantumly and
that's why we have a better value
yes
um let me make one more further one
further observation
so which is that the so the classical
value
which is for d equals one um we've seen
this before of course is going to be
less than the quantum value which allows
um
any kind of d and i want to add one more
here and again i'm not going to insist
but um
i can write here the sdp value
okay this would be um the natural sdp
relaxation of the classical value of the
game and it
shows up here the reason you have this
upper bounded holds is basically what i
wrote
uh here on the left on the left board
one way to think of these here is as an
inner product between two vectors right
u
etc dot v etc
and these vectors satisfy the natural
constraints that you'd put on an sdp
relaxation so
you know the sum of their squared norms
will be one i could enforce that they're
orthogonal for every question if i
wanted
so from a quantum strategy i can define
an assignment a solution to the
to the sdp the sopra said earlier i
don't know if he's
still awake or no
okay there's something called uh oh
you're there okay so
from a quantum strategy you can get a
vector solution to the basic sdp
relaxation
of the game it's going to satisfy all
the constraints the quantum strategy has
a little bit more structure these
vectors come from
come from somewhere and this is what
we're trying to use this extra structure
because we know that if we used only the
vector struct then
we'd i'd never get to an np harvest
result right for an sdp so
um right but this is not important for
the remainder of the talk it was only
for those of you who are already
familiar with these
sdb relaxations okay and the claims that
we've already seen before that are
pretty obvious claims so i'm making two
of them the first is that the classical
value is related to the maximum
satisfiability of the
formula so if the formula
can satisfy all the clauses or certain
frac this is the maximum of fraction
of clauses i can satisfy with any
assignment
then the value of the game is bigger it
can do at least as much
and you can check that the value it
won't be much more so you have
because of this consistency checking etc
the correspondence is not exact but you
have something like this
um are you using d in two different ways
as dimension and yeah what's the other
way
oh yeah sorry um
d will always be the dimension um except
when it's not
so so here it's not
yeah sorry here it's just a bit which is
the bit that bob answers
for his question x which should be w
so from now on it'll be the dimension
okay so this is clear it's an easy
exercise it's kind of what i described
on the first slide
and another thing that we know from the
magic square is that there exists some
formula
not quite the magic square the multi
square is not freestyle it had disparity
constraints we can make it into a
three-star formula
such that the formula is not satisfiable
right because it comes
from the magic square
but the value of the quantum game
that's associated to it
is equal to one so this inequality here
doesn't hold if i put the quantum value
right and that's the that's the problem
that we have
all right
okay so that that's all stuff we had
seen before um okay now
uh maybe a more interesting remark so
i'm going to define
it's not going to be needed you don't
need to define it but um
i'll define the commuting quantum value
of the game so
i define it informally
what is this the same thing but i
restrict
or constrain all the bob's measurements
so all these
matrices measurement operators that bob
applies
uh okay well there's again a d
to commute
right let's say let's say let's define
this
and so now i make a claim which is that
this value
is equal to the classical value so in
other words if i knew for a fact that
just bob is restricted to applying
measurements that always commute
for any pair of questions then they
wouldn't be able to use
anything about entanglement this would
be wasted whatever d
i'm not placing restrictions on d here
you know how obvious this is um i think
it's worth
just checking
the proof is easy what i can do is that
if this
is the case i can define a new
measurement so i'll define a new
measurement
which now is this global measurement now
this thing that we said before doesn't
exist because in which order you measure
the questions etc now i can define it i
can define
let's call it c it's going to be indexed
by all the variables
and here answers for every possible
variable and i'm just going to take the
product of all the b guys
so b x 1 a 1 times so this is times
b x and b n and adjusting the product so
so this is meaningful because they
commute if they didn't
well i could take the product but it
wouldn't be permission it wouldn't be
positive
but because they commute this is makes
sense it's positive
and if i sum over all answers i'm just
summing each of the terms and i get the
identity
so this is a measurement it's well
defined measurement because the b's
commute
it's a measurement that doesn't depend
on anything i mean i indexed it by all
the variables here but
fine all the variables we know this is
the formula everyone knows the formula
so i can remove it
another claim is that because the b's
commute um
i have an equivalent strategy for bob if
my original strategy for bob was okay i
received question
x1 i make this measurement produce the
answer a1 that's the strategy
now i do a different strategy i receive
question x1
put it aside make this measurement get
answers for all possible questions
and then send back the answer that was
associated to x1 so send back a1
that's a different strategy but it
produces exactly the same correlations
if i measure this thing but i ignore all
but the first answer
is corresponding to marginalizing all by
the first answer so i'm summing over
them
so i sum all these b matrices but
because they sum to identity they all go
away and it's as if i had applied b so
it's the same strategy
it's the same strategy for bob except
that this measurement i can make it even
before the game starts right because i
don't need to know what my question is
so before the game starts bob applies
this measurement he gets answers
for every possible questions and when he
gets his questions he provides the
answer
so it's a classical strategy
so what i've said is that um if bob's
strategy in the game
is made of operators that all commute
then
i have a way to find an assignment to my
constraint satisfaction problem which is
define this measurement which is a
global measurement doesn't depend on the
question measure it
get all the answers simultaneously and
then use these answers as part of the
game and that's a classical strategy
so this proves this increasingly it's
kind of clear i mean i'm saying the
measurements commute so they're
compatible so
i can make all of them simultaneously
and there's no quantum anymore
intuitively
it should be clear and formally it's
also clear it's it's easy
but now it suggests something right it's
saying what we knew all around but it's
saying that
uh what we need uh in order for this
to go down below one to respect some
kind of inequality like this
is that we need to be enforcing some
kind of commutativity
on bob's strategy if we manage to
enforce this to make it the case that
his measurement operators commute maybe
even a tiny bit
then we'll you know be back on track
because we'll be making the quantum
strategies closer to the classical
strategies
um this will be tighter and then we
won't have this this happen anyway
let us just prove one direction with the
other directions obvious
oh yeah yeah because classical strategy
is always compute it's a one-dimensional
everything commutes in one dimension i
mean
you say okay what i proved is um
is this right yeah but the other
other direction is obvious
um
inequality because you gave a particular
commuting
strategy yeah but how do you know that
all commuting strategies
no no that's how you do uh two different
sites so to do this side
i take a commuting strategy and i say i
can make a classical strategy out of it
so the best classical will be better so
this is this inequality how do i do the
other side i start from the classical
strategy
i make a commuting strategy out of it
and then the best computing will do
better right
but making commuting strategy out of
classical strategy is not doing anything
yeah what about alice huh
why are all is
it clear that all that all her veterans
can commute uh no
um but it doesn't matter so i don't need
it so i could uh it's not needed for the
proof so
why is this i thought that a
classical alice would be part of the
definition of just w
with no star in the classical version
sorry can you say it again just the way
he defined it
i thought that the definition of w of g
was both bomb analysis
that's correct that's correct so i
haven't uh um
you're right i haven't fully specified
what is my classical strategy so i
started from a commuting strategy
where only bob commutes not alice but
now
now i'm defining a strategy where
everyone is classical
and i didn't need to assume that alice
commuted
so i thought that here you just found
the strategy for paul yeah i didn't say
what alice does
so it's it's a good point um so let me
do it again so
um it's a complicated classical strategy
because it involves setting stuff up but
so before the game starts but this is
allowed we set stuff up so how do we set
stuff up
we actually create that state um
bob measures it using the thing that
they described there and he writes down
all the answers
and then he goes and gets ready for the
game to start alice she keeps the state
everything and she puts it there and
then when bob receives his question he
answers what he wrote down when alice
receives her question
she makes the measurement on her half of
the state and she has everything anyways
and then she sends back the answers
so you can tell me this is not quite a
classical strategy but i'll say
it's okay what's important is that it
doesn't use any entanglement because
alice was using everything and so you
could make it into
a classical strategy by saying she could
simulate all this stuff she doesn't need
a
thanks
all right so
don't worry we're we're kind of making
progress um
um we have a couple more things to do
and then we'll be done
so i'm going to define uh two little
gadgets or two little sub games that
we're going to add
to our three-star game and to make to
make into a game that you could call
entanglement robust i mean for which if
the formula is not satisfiable then the
value of the game
is tricky less than one this is the
question no
sorry um
so there's two small games that i want
to use and explain their utility
and then we'll add them to the
three-star game and then we'll be done
so the first is a consistency game the
other is a confused game
consistency game is is a game leonard
was asking
earlier
the motivation for this introducing this
game is to find a way
to measure uh closeness between
strategies to say what it means that two
strategies are close
so i have classical strategies um these
are just lists of answers
to all possible questions and it's clear
to say that
what two of these are close right i'm
just saying that two classical
strategies are close
if they give the same answer to most
questions
quantum strategies it's less clear right
what is it the case
how do you say that two quantum
strategies are close yes
shouldn't you first go to
non-deterministic possible strategies
yeah you're right but actually that
would be almost as tricky as doing it in
the quantum case
um so you know you could say let's make
it deterministic and let's worry about
it
but but there you have an issue which is
um
whether they define on the same
probability space or not so if you
define them on the same property space
then there's a
meaning to saying that you know for
every
fixing of the randomness or for every
atom in your probability space
they give the same answer on most
questions which questions they give the
same answer to might depend on the
atom so that would be one definition
but i'll do the quantum right away it'll
give an answer
but thinking productively about your
question would would give an answer to
the quantum case so it's
um because so you could answer that at
different levels for instance you could
say well i want to say i mean it's
pretty clear right i defined what the
quantum strategy is so
what is when is it the two quantum
strategies are close when they're close
right so when these entangled states are
close
as vectors and when these matrices are
close an operator norm maybe or
something right
that's the definition of being close but
it's it's too strong a definition it's
not going to be useful
when i analyze games because when you
analyze games the only thing that you
see the only thing that matters is the
probability distributions is the what
the verifier can see in the game
there's no way that you can say anything
about the measurement operators
themselves whether it's useful to say
anything about the measure
well okay for instance if you do a
unitary transformation everything they
are not going to be close at
all and yet it's the same if you do
local unitaries yeah
yeah i mean another way to say it is
that the these measurement operators
could have a lot of junk uh there could
be a lot of stuff in some corner
for example some corner of space
intuitively in which
psi the state has no mass then i don't
care about this
so at least it should take both of them
into account right
the strongest definition is too strong
but the weakest definition
would be to say okay i just want to
preserve the local distribution so two
strategies are close if
for every pair of questions or most pair
of questions i get the same
or close in statistical distance
distribution and pairs of answers
right now that's too weak um
why is it too weak because i want to be
we're going to be composing games we
want to be able to use that and
having a distribution which just only
talks about the
distribution of answers is is not going
to be something that i'm going to be
able to use when i compose games so i
want something a little bit stronger i
want to say that two strategies are
close
if they're close when i play
any game using them if they're part of
different types of bigger games
roughly so this is a
i'm going to give two definitions
they're equivalent one of them is
mathematical and the other involves
the game i'll give the mathematical
definitions first so i'll say that
if we have two strategies a and b i'll
define maybe
the distance let's call it distance
it's going to depend on the state
between a and b
and it's going to be this it's going to
be
it's going to be slightly game dependent
but not too much so let's see
let me write it right
it's very it's it's it's sort of very
natural um
so it's just the uh difference the l2
norms
between the vectors after you apply
the measurement operators um on the left
half for instance of the vector
you just take the average over all
possible questions so for this i need to
have a distribution
on questions so this definition is
distribution dependent
okay some overall answers are with this
so that's that's the mathematical
definition another way to think about it
is to say that the post measurement
states are
are close after you make after you make
the measurement
and then let's give another definition
this one i'll write
this is the game definition i'll write
consistency between a and b
and this will be simply defined as the
probability
that
alice well that there's no alice in bob
so there's a and b
there's this measurement this also
depends on psi
these measurements provide the same
answer
the same output right same answer
when asked
the same question
right you imagine that um so it's the
success priority in a certain game which
is this consistency game
which is a simple game where you'd
imagine that you send the same question
to alice into bob
and they give you answers a a prime
let's say b and they win if a equals b
um so you're defining the distance on
strategies here
but um i uh was under
the impression from earlier that a
strategy was a
set of povms and a state
so are you assuming that these two
strategies
have the same state associated with them
the same state yes
that's correct very good point actually
uh yeah i haven't been precise about
that yes
so it's only defined um for strategies
that use the same state same set of
questions same set of answers and same
state
okay would the with the distance
measured generalized to just
um if you had a different state
associated with just the altar i mean
i could write it down but i don't know
if i could do anything with it yeah
everything okay
but the state might have been well
just to clarify that if all you had was
a bunch of joint epr pairs and this
that was your starting point didn't then
it doesn't seem like just to use some
[ __ ] to say that
that's sort of with you or or where is
it assumption
which assumption well what is beside
what is psi doing for them right so
maybe it's a bunch of choice
yeah i mentioned this in the open
questions actually um it is an
assumption
so um um
it's a restriction for the players to
say you have to use zpr plays there's
games for which you can't do as well if
you're forced to do
the operators take that big and
badly right so right that's another
answer which is
there is some other state which is not
dpr pairs which is good
for every game a priori we know what
that state is
um so we could fix that state that's
good maybe that would
say that well actually it doesn't really
matter if you're right but that's it
you could just take the tensor product
of the two
states yes but then a would act on one
and b on the other and then i'm not
so that would be sort of equivalent to
just replacing this by
phi but i'm not sure that would get me
very far
um okay so there's um
two claims here that i'm not gonna write
down not proof um
because the audience is getting tired
and i wanna get to the point so
but they're easy to prove easy exercises
so one claim i already made which is
these two
are equivalent measures
uh in the sense that if this is small
then this is high and vice versa in a
very linear sense right this is almost
one minus this
but not quite so
if the strategies win in the consistency
game then they're close if they're close
they win in the consistency game
okay why aren't they equal don't you
just kind of align your question with
the
the vector difference or why aren't they
why isn't it
equal sorry oh why aren't they equal um
no so there's a there's an important uh
difference between the two and
see this is something i should say the
first thing is that
okay here's one answer to your question
d
of a and a equals zero this is pretty
clear
this is not always equal to one uh
for a and a um so what if they're just
always
for instance they think of a random
strategy something completely randomized
you're not being consistent you're not
winning in that game
so actually i should qualify what i said
before the equivalence is between
this being small and both
this and the a a guy sorry under the
assumption that
the a guy is large so i should write it
so the lemma or the claim is that
suppose that a is a nice strategy
in the sense that it's consistent with
itself
right so it's self-consistent then
okay i'm not going to write it but then
they're close to each other so here you
have to add that
that if different then they should
answer differently right otherwise it's
trivial
sorry so if you ask
different things then they have to
answer differently
otherwise they can just always answer
zero
to everything and then it holds that yes
of course it's easy to win in this game
but that's not the point um the
it's like this right it's not hard to
come up with an a such that this is zero
i can define it for you but so so this
would okay
that was a bad answer maybe a better
answer is this is going to be a sub game
in the i'm not going to play this for
itself for instance when i play
i'm going to compose with the three-star
game and now instead of doing this
we'll probably yeah um i'll try to wrap
up um
with probability half i'll do this game
and with probability half
let's say i tell both of them to play
bob um and they have to provide the same
answer
but when you play bob you don't know if
the other guy is playing bob
you know if you're new then of course
everyone always answers zero but that
won't
you know
another way to see the difference
between the two quantities which is
makes the equivalent it's not completely
obvious is that here
i think of the operators acting on the
same half of psy
whereas here they're acting on different
halves so there's something to prove
all right so i'll define my last game
and then
which is the confusion game so this is
the important game
but it's very simple simple but useful
so it's like this um there's an alice
and a bob again so you choose
alice bob at random
and then now you choose two questions
q q prime independently
at random so i'm leaving the at random
vague again this is
using some fixed distribution right for
instance if it's three star
uniform distribution on the on the
clauses qq prime at random
and then you send the unordered pair
qq prime to alice
and you send let's say the first one
this was unordered so it doesn't matter
q to bob
so i just got two questions bob got one
then you receive
a a prime from alice she has to provide
you two answers
and b from bob
and you check
well in that case a equals b right if if
alice says
a was for q and a prime was for q prime
then i checked that they gave the same
answer on q
the point is that alice doesn't know
which of her two questions she's being
checked against with respect to bobby so
it's kind of a sophisticated version of
the
consistency game
right again it's you know easy to win
this party one but that's not the
uh point what's the point so the point
is as
follows the important thing you can
prove and it's it's not hard i
you know i don't want to get into the
proof but it's just a few lines of
algebra
which is that if we have a strategy for
that game so strategy for that game will
be measurements for alice and
measurements for bob
and let's suppose that i have a strategy
that wins in this game
so i'll write it conf for confusing
just like consistency of a and b
suppose that this is large one minus
epsilon
and suppose also that
b the b measurements
would win you know if i was to play the
consistency game telling both
both guys your bob they would also win
so the two conditions then
can you read i'm writing stuff really
low on the camera it works okay
so then we have the following two
strategies are equivalent
we have that so using my distance
measure that i had before
psi and psi is the same state that's
used by everyone all the time
between two different measurements one
is the a
i'll just write q q prime so we remember
it's the a's that's here
and these measurements are close to
other measurements that i could
construct from the bs
i'm going to write it in a non-symmetric
way i should write it symmetrically but
and it's just a product of the two
when there's a little loss in the in the
parameters here root epsilon
okay i'm saying this is the distance
measure so i'm saying
suppose my players you know if i'm to
play these two games with them
and they use strategies a and b whatever
that are successful in those games
then it must be the case that alice's
strategy on q and q prime
is actually close to some kind of a
product strategy that i could obtain
from bob's measurements
for those of you who know the proof of
this the intuition for why this would
hold is
kind of related to the um
how's it going almost gentle measurement
lemma
the idea is that
if you win in that game alice makes a
measurement
when bob makes his measurement on the
corresponding queue
we know what his answer is going to be
his answer is going to be the one that
alice provided because they're
consistent if they succeed well in the
game
so it means that when alice has made her
measurement if bob makes his measurement
the answer is already determined
so the state is not going to change in
particular if bob makes his
measurement q and then q prime or q
prime and then q the state doesn't
change it's the same thing
yeah i mean since that's not always
hermitian i know
like root b so both are true um but this
is also true like
because i mean this definition you can
use it even if b is not hermitian and
and it's true um but you're right the
proper way to write it would have been
to
have say b q in the middle and sandwich
it by two roots two square roots of b q
primes and it would also be correct
all right um i'm also
confused so a and b are you referring
them to strategies by allison bob but
um
i'm mixing up a bit too many things but
uh so when i write a and b
here they're not alice or bob but
they're that's why i wrote the queues i
guess just just to make it clear that
a is just the measurement operators that
are associated to this kind of questions
in the game and these are the
measurement operators that are
associated to this kind of questions
and again which when i wrote this here i
thought of the first as being alice's
measurements and the second as bob's
measurements
but both of them can be meaningfully
applied on either side of the state and
they
you know they're just two different sets
of questions that correspond to two
different kinds of questions in the game
i'm saying that they produce the same
results whether you apply this one or
this one
so this forces bob's strategy to be
almost commuting
right right so aaron is ahead of us
though
this in itself actually has interesting
consequences for instance you can think
of it as a direct product test and
you can use this to get some repetition
results but i'm not getting into that
one consequence of this and the triangle
inequality for the distance measure that
you know it's going to hold maybe
there's a square you have to but
is that the distance between b and then
b q and then b q prime and
b q prime and then b q when they're both
close to the same thing because this q
q prime there was unordered right as
well
so it's close is root epsilon
so i know that if i play this little
test here and the players succeed with
high probability then bob's measurements
operators
approximately commute up to some small
epsilon in this distance measure
so um i'm not going to get into why
you know there's a long story to tell
about the difference between
approximately commuting and exactly
commuting i'm not going to tell it
i'm going to tell you what is the final
game we play and what is the result
about it and then
it'll be done then we can have more
questions
okay okay so here's the two
modifications that i make to my game so
it's going to be a little bit
complicated more complicated
but not too much more so this is the
three stat star game
the game is like this with probability
one third i'm going to do three
different things so one third
do
so the first thing that i do a is this
okay that i did before we probably
wanted b
i'm going to play the
consistency game
and then i'll write here on the
variables
not the clauses we only care about bob
so what this means
is that i choose just one variable at
random
send it to both guys and ask them what
value do you assign to that variable and
i check that the answers are the same
and then the last thing is i'm going to
play the confused game
okay also on the variables so now it
means that i take
two random variables two variables at
random
send both to alice and one of them to
bob and they reply answers and i checked
that the answer is match
for the answer that was the question
that was sent to both right so so do
these two things
that's it and then the
so i keep losing the eraser i don't know
ah okay how come they have only one
so what's the theorem you're headed
towards yeah i'm writing it right now
okay and then yeah and that's the last
thing i want to write on the board so
the theorem is uh the theorem is that
um take a formula right phi
so suppose there's two parts to it so
suppose phi
is satisfiable then
the value of this game
three stat star
associated to five is one right okay
fine you can win with priority one
because the formula was satisfiable this
is fine
and then the other part is suppose
phi is not satisfiable
let's say it's um
one minus epsilon then
the value is not one so we don't have
this magic square thing that happens
anymore
the omega star of the basic three start
game could be one with the three side
star game
is at most one minus and then there's a
big loss here um
n the number of variables times root
epsilon
basically because i got root epsilon
here for every pair
and then i have my end measurements so i
get a loss of a factor
and here so that's the theorem i wanted
and then the corollary
is that um deciding
between these values for the
preset game is one or
is at most
let's say n cubed for say t n is the
number of variables so this is np
hardware right
here but why something um yeah n squared
times the constant i just wanted to
i don't know why you have a square why
why isn't it one over one to the minus
one times
i i want this to be strictly um uh
you know small i mean four i see there's
a n you know
so oh epsilon is right it's n root
epsilon so i want to take epsilon to be
at most a constant over n squared small
constant over n squared i mean that's
good so formula does not decry
the n times square root of f okay it
should be like
epsilon squared over n yeah epsilon
squared over n
would look like much nicer
no no of course no but no no no but
might look like oh oh sorry i did it the
wrong way around
you're right you're right you're right
i'm sorry
um yes yes
what should it be epsilon squared over n
so i want epsilon to be
no n no no no oh
i mean n should not be a multiplier it
should be in the denominator
yeah yeah you're right you're right
oh i see because i'm doing the sorry i
guess it should be something like this
i think what i wrote there is still
current
so so this is um well it doesn't appear
in this form but it's uh
um the first to prove this np harness
for two player games this is uh
ito kobayashi matsumoto 2009.
they were building on some paper of
kempe kobayashi matsumoto
sort of at the time we didn't really
look at it in in this way
um so
yeah um yeah yeah i should stop i'm
gonna stop um
um i wanted to have some philosophy but
um
yeah so so for me this is like um this
is
when you do reductions between
constrained satisfaction problems right
you have a theory of
gadgets and reductions that preserve
approximation that preserve
uh the maximum satisfiability of certain
assignments
and you understand very well what kind
of gadgets you can perform and what's
their
their effect you can make you know these
games you can change the constraint
graph make it into an expander you can
do
different things you also you can study
uh you know you have
direct product tests and you have all
kinds of
gadgets or tests that you use in order
to achieve
certain things or about gains or
constraint satisfaction problems
and i think we don't have such a thing
for quantum games and i think it would
be useful to have so this is why i
present it in this way
um because it people don't think about
it in this way i mean i was just
preparing this and trying to
clean things up a little bit and i think
these
thinking of this in this way that when
you play these multiplayer games you can
play different subgames confusion game
consistency game i had
others this there's a for instance
there's a anti-commuting
uh gadget and this is a gadget that you
can use to enforce that the
entanglement dimension is very large
okay so they're all some kind of
and then you have a toolbox and then if
you try to achieve
something called dimension width for
instance you're going to use this
anti-commutativity if you're trying to
in this case i was trying to do
something in a way that's not
interesting i'm trying to prevent my
quantum guys from being quantum
make them commute and i know i have this
confusion game i can absorb
even though if you study devices the
kind of things you really was talking
about before it seems like it's it's it
would be very useful to have a good
understanding of
um these different objects and what
consequences
so this is yeah so
if i understood this right b and c here
are to make
basically to make alice involved use a
classical strategy for part a
yeah but but so i thought the part of
the rule was
that they know what kind of question
they're i mean if they know that they're
getting a b
type question can't they arrange ah no
no
no no no no the types of questions
they're not a
b and c they're just um alice bob
which which in that case is just a
clause or variable but it seems like
you're not
but the word function for their answer
is determine probability is that power
to think about
the what sort i mean the reward function
is different
in the case yes um yes so
so for example so in that okay let's
let's be the player from the point of
view of the player in that game what do
you see
you get asked only one of two possible
things either a clause or a variable
that's what you see and in your mind
what you should be doing is
giving answers or assignments of values
to what you were asked about the three
variables or one variable
that are part of a satisfying assignment
for the whole
formula this is what you're supposed to
be doing you're supposed to have agreed
both players on an assignment of
variables that satisfies all the clauses
and when you're asked one variable or
three variables or whatever this is what
you answer this is what you're supposed
to do
so you don't know for instance if you're
asked a variable
you don't know where to win if it's
satisfiable but the game that you've
defined here involves other parts
yes yes yes yes right i'm just saying
the player is not aware of which part is
but i thought that in order for this to
be a game you've got to tell the player
what
like the function is the referee is
using to evaluate their answers
yes and they know it it's written here
on the board but it's just
if you're told hey you're being bob
and here's a variable give me the value
this is what you're told
and you know the specificity of the game
you know that it could be the case that
the other guy
is playing alice in which case you're
here or it could be the case that the
other guy
is bob in which case maybe you're here
is another bob and you're here so it's
the same kind of indeterminacy as we had
before
what you don't know is what the other
guy is and in this
particular type of game it is the case
that you know
what the other guy is i mean it matters
in terms of what's going on but you
oh
yeah the thing that i wasn't
understanding was that the referee is
allowed to
the function that they apply to the
answers that alice and bob give
is allowed to have like they're allowed
to flip a three-sided coin
in order and then evaluate it using
criteria a b
or c yeah yeah but that's not really
more different than um
what we had just in the basic three-star
game where
in a way i flipped a coin to select the
clause and then i flipped a coin to
select a variable
in the clause and so when i asked bob
about the variable
um or let's say sorry when i asked alice
about the clause
she doesn't know what the other coin was
so she doesn't know
if she's being checked against variable
number one two or three
with respect to bob and you could think
of this as being as playing three
different games
one game is i ask the first variable to
book the other games i as the second
variable to bob
so it's the same kind and of course this
is necessary that there's some unknown
in the thanks
do you have a question or no i'm sorry
so
behind you i thought so would the
natural analog be that
constant factor approximation to this is
np heart or qa house
that's a good question um let's start by
proving that it's np hard and
so um it depends where you start really
i mean it's a good question um
you know it seems natural to classify so
okay classically it's np hard
so at least i know where to get started
if i want to prove that the quantity for
instance i look at uh
he reads proof of pcp theorem and try to
that also involves a lot of gadgets do
they go through or not i mean this is a
program i think it's interesting program
we can convert
okay could it be qma hard so
in principle it could be and we've seen
these results that umash mentioned
about testing or that that anne
mentioned also where
within qma you're trying to verify the
existence of a quantum witness right
here you're a purely classical verifier
running this game and you have a
classical interaction
so can you really verify your qma hard
problem by having this kind of
interaction yeah maybe you can because
this is what these results on
uh q map equals mipstar et cetera are
saying so
um so maybe it is
but um it thank you i have no idea how
you'd get started but
no it's it's not there's no upper bound
on the thing so so it's not
yeah i guess there's
i think qma is kind of natural but i i i
definitely wouldn't bet anything on this
being np
or or on np or qma being though
but i think some of the measures results
in these tests they
are new from just a year or two ago and
they are pointing to
the possibility for having qma hardness
whereas before we thought that np would
be the the natural answer anything
because of these new results it's not
clear anymore and this w
star you said there's two definitions
what are you using here
oh i'm using this one the limit of the
finite dimensional answers
and the other what is this so supremum
over all dimensions and strategies in
that dimension
oh i see so it's a limit so i can yeah
actually i'm not there's another
definition which is equivalent in finite
dimensions
but when you take the limit they're not
and you oh we don't know if they are or
not
it didn't yeah but i could say what it
is you have a fixed game and you allow
arbitrary dimension i see this okay
yeah so i mean it's like saying i allow
arbitrary strategies
which arbitrary but finite dimension
yes right so and you could debate that i
mean some people say why not allow
infinite
it's just then you have to work with
sister algebras and i'm not so fluent in
anyone else so actually it's
it is in qma now or because
um because we are talking about the
approximate version
so so if we fixed
the if we fix the dimension okay
it would be in qma right what do you
mean by if you fix the dimension
this is in exponential time in the
dimension
because the that's the size of my or
exponential space that's the size if i
oh sorry polynomial if i fix the
dimension
yeah it's an exponential time in the
dimension if i fix the dimension
the strategy is an object that has size
you know d
squared times the size of my game the
number of questions and so
in time exponential indeed i can but but
maybe it's in qma 2 or something like
that
if you fix the dimension if it's in oh
um
so this might have been asked before but
is there a natural definition for a
metric
on the space of all quantum strategies
so that that goes that's not what i had
written before you mean
that's um that's completely game
independent you mean or
uh yeah i mean like i mean i suggested
the definition but it had some drawbacks
so i did use the same state
and it depended on the question sets and
answer sets
right right okay yes i was wondering if
i could lead to a general definition one
thing i've seen in the literature
is they um define the distance between
two strategies according to
both the distance between the initial
states and also the post measurement
states
and sort of like the maximum so if all
the all of those happen to be close then
they say that the strategy the closing
security centers might
lead to the same thing okay but here
again to define
post measurements you know you have
different measurements for different
questions so you have to say how you
incorporate the
questions right you could do everything
coherently maybe you have the
but still you need the distribution on
questions
i think it makes sense to take the game
into account because the strategy is
anyways indexed by questions the
questions are not arbitrary objects
they're part of come from the game and
there's an
implicit distribution of the questions
you could you could make like the uh
the questions themselves the classical
register right you could do that
yeah yeah so then yeah
let me take do okay well let me
zen go ahead mario has had this load of
questions and or we should read the
audience right now
so um this definition of similar
strategies
um is there a way to
is there a sense that you can mod out by
that uh that
you know sort of create a new strategy
on a different space so that
you know you don't have to that should
exist or um
i don't know if you think about it even
classically i don't know
exactly what it means or if it's useful
classically you have a feel for what two
similar stretch like examples well
think of you know vectors that are close
i mean at some level that's that's just
what it is
then what does it mean to mod out by
vectors that are close so you want to
create equivalence classes of
vectors that are i guess i was under
some big impression that
though somehow the strategies were in
some sense different but not
not different in this measure is that
wrong
oh yeah they can be different as uh
operators in terms of operating
but be close in that measure yeah that
can happen so so that was a
so so how do i relate that so you said
i think convectors that are close but
the operators are not close so what am i
thinking about
um
i didn't get the question um
similar strategies that are actually
that are measured to be similar but are
different
i said i don't have a feel for an
example of that oh
no no just just think of a case where
the um
the measurement operators are very
different right in some corner
so the operating room is very different
but this the state the entangled state
so has no mass on that corner so for all
practical purposes
and for all you care they're the same so
isn't that an example where you should
be able to mod out by that i mean you
should sort of be able to
but yeah but but it's not but it's not
that easy so
yeah you could you could say for
instance okay if psi has some small
coefficients in some corner let's just
some small schmidt coefficients for
instance let's just get rid of that
um and you and then now we could be
talking about the operators
but it's not um um it's tricky to do
that because the
if you think about what psi looks like
typically right what's this universal
state the schmidt coefficients
they scale like one over square root
so it's not easy at all to say
there's no clear tail like it it's a
divergent
it's it's a complicated question to to
try to look at um
you wouldn't know i mean or just
questions yeah well
um we need a moderator who takes
questions i don't know we'll speak up um
there's a gfg
i just wanted to ask if if three if
three players games are fundamentally
different like for instance can it be
that to prove
that these are qma
in qma but three players are not in qma
can it be
or yeah um so for example the
status of things right now is that the
approximation problem for three player
games is np hard and for two player
games we don't know
for example we know it could be in p for
two player games and np hard for three
player games mean constant
constant approximation right this is
right constant approximation
um so people are there's something some
intuition where
they could be different between because
monogamy because tripartite entanglement
is very different than bipartite
and some other intuition which is to say
well you know as soon as you have two
it's the same right
well you have the question if you don't
have it anymore there's another question
so how do you compare
your technique and uh
um they're similar except that you have
to
it's like going from what we did there
is uh
cook levin or i don't know basic so you
it's it's
similar ideas but you have to analyze
further games or tests so these low
degree tests linearity
well actually you just load degree tests
yeah yeah yeah so there also but the
modification is going to become much
heavier it's going to be the same kind
of motif
modification that you do when you prove
the pcp theory you
also you could say that when you prove
this video you start from the three-star
game but then you start doing very
complicated
building complicated games on top of
that right where you you stop
asking directly for the variables or the
clauses but you think of these as being
encoded in values or polynomials and you
ask
about the values of polymers at other
points and so you do these kinds of
things
so you're about you started still adding
new gadgets to the game
yeah in a way you're modifying the game
yeah but you to the point where you lose
track of the original game i mean you're
not playing this anymore
yeah yeah
so um i asked earlier about the
state dependence of that and
it was mentioned that there is a
a best state that you know what is that
state
it's patrick still around yeah so um
there's a nice paper by patrick hayden
and vin van dam that
explores this state it's because
embezzlement states
there's many you could have but here's
one uh definition it's
it's just it's just like this so i mean
there's one for every dimension
and you need to take it into large
enough dimension um
but it's going to look like one over
a constant and then there's a one
dimension
okay so the point is is the scaling of
the schmidt coefficients right that they
have this uh
they decrease but like inverse square
root so pretty slow so it's definitely
not flat definitely not a maximum time
state
and also something that you can't chop
off so easily because the decay is so
small
and there's there's variations on that
but this is one that will work so it has
the property that
for any other state that you want it has
the property that for any other state
that you like
any state you can generate that other
state
from this one by making local operations
local unitaries
that's why it's called embezzlement
because all that matters is the schmidt
coefficients
right up to local operations but that
that they're allowed to do so
thanks
okay maybe we should stop and thank
tomafra for a great time
and we'll reconvene tomorrow morning the
first half will be at 9 30
with coffee before that